twitter stock is up after they posted
their fastest revenue growth since 2014
on thursday twitter announced q2
earnings that came in much stronger than
expected
on friday the stock was up four percent
and is up 10
since the beginning of the week their
market cap is now 57
billion nearing its all-time high of
over 60 billion which they hit back in
february of 2021
coincidentally that's another profit g
short q2 revenue
was 1.19 billion which was 74
year-over-year growth the largest
year-over-year growth since 2014.
twitter's year-over-year profitability
also increased dramatically as they
turned a 1.38 billion
loss in q2 of 2020 to a 65 million
profit in q2 of 2021. that is the
playbook
in silicon valley which is you invest
you invest and people say oh your money
losing your money losing
and at a certain point the business uh
is so
strong the foundation is there and the
growth is there and then you flip over
into profitability
and then everybody is whoa now we should
buy the stock
we've seen this over and over again
amazon being the canonical example
and let's not forget prof g
roof the dog prof g a grown man on
testosterone shots
who calls himself a big dog called for
jack dorsey
firing back in november of 2020 check
out this 50-second clip
let me start with the last part the
change of role should he be he should be
fired
any board that lets it part this is a
big company with thousands of employees
that plays an important role in the
discourse of society
and about 1 pm every day he pieces out
and he goes to another firm
i'm on the board of several i've been on
the board of several public companies
and i've never met an individual who can
manage a company like this
part time so unless there's some
superpowers we're not aware of
i think it's just starting right there
the fact that he's a part-time ceo and
89 percent of his wealth
is tied up in his afternoon job renders
him
totally incapable of providing the
attention and leadership that this
company
needs and distinctive the distinct of
the regulatory conversation i think just
think if you look at product innovation
twitter looks
scarily 2015. so i just don't
the role for jack dorsey is for him to
declare victory and leave and be kicked
upstairs
to chairman okay so there you have it a
prof g call and since then twitter you
guessed it is up 80
thanks prof g for all the profits if
profg
gives you a prediction do yourself a
favor fade that
take the other side of the bet and
you're gonna print money
uh and congratulations to twitter on
their enormous success uh
and everybody else who prof g dunks on
congratulations on
proving him wrong which is pretty easy
to do and it's also worth noting that q2
2020 was the hardest hit due to the
covet advertiser panic
since the start of 2021 twitter has
introduced spaces twitter blue it's for
subscription service
uh that's three dollars a month their
tip jar and they're rolling out super
follow
soon which will act as like a patreon
only fans like membership where you you
know give content just to that group of
people
and obviously patreon and only fans were
largely built off of people's
twitter and instagram followings so now
it's as if
those businesses are going to basically
be built into twitter and only fans is
for
adult content so if those adult kind of
folks or models
whatever you put them into in terms of
descriptors
they don't need to have an only fans or
patreon they could just do it all on
twitter it's going to be pretty
interesting so
the big lesson here from both companies
is product velocity
gets new users increase revenue it's
really that simple folks i talk to the
founders i invest in all the time keep
iterating
keep coming up with new ideas keep
making your existing products better
keep delighting your users the revenue
will and snap and twitter
were stagnant for years they were
sideways trying to figure it out
don't give up go public and keep
grinding this is why i was a little
disappointed that slack
sold to salesforce i would have liked to
see them just keep grinding it out even
if they're sideways just keep fighting
sometimes people want to cash their
chips and i guess jack dorsey
who is turns out a great leader both of
his companies square and twitter
which profg derided for years are
absolutely crushing it
so here's jack's quote as we enter the
second half of 2021
we are shipping more learning faster and
hiring remarkable
talent for example our increased
shipping cadence contributed to reaching
206 million
average monetizable dows monthly dows
in q2 up 11 year over year and three
percent
quarter of a quarter there's a
tremendous opportunity to get the whole
world to use twitter and i agree with
him and i think
it's possible not counting the after
hours move twitter shares are up more
than 30
since the start of 2021 which is almost
double the s p
500 which is up 16 the same time period
twitter's ad business just boomed in q2
was up 87 year over year
to 1 billion and total ad engagement was
up 32
that's people clicking on the ads
commenting on them etc i think what
we're seeing here is twitter
got its groove back on the product basis
and
haters like profg who have produced
nothing in the world
but hate and trying to do sound bites
and be clever
they don't matter they don't matter
they're just haters what matters is the
people who build
and the people who build are more
important in the world
than the critics even if the critics get
a little too much attention
from time to time okay healthy and happy
employees create successful companies
and that's a fact com for business can
help your employees be their best selves
at work
and you can partner with the number one
mental fitness app
to provide support and tools for your
employees
com can kickstart mental well-being
initiatives by
empowering employees to stress less rest
better
and build resilience com has an entire
library of content
specifically designed for the workplace
which includes
lo-fi music playlists to get you in flow
quick breathing breaks guided
meditations and hundreds
of soothing sleep stories i know
sleep we don't want you sleeping at work
but we do want you to get a great
night's sleep
the night before that big meeting or
that big pitch or you're working on that
great project so
they even have programs tailored for
mental health and productivity
like their mindfulness at work series
millions of employees at over 600
companies
like lincoln iterable and universal
studios use
com for business obviously you guys know
i'm an investor in com
i've loved the product forever and i've
always wondered what are they going to
get into the enterprise well here they
are
so right now com is offering a free
well-being ebook for hr and benefit
leaders
and one month free after you attend a
free demo at com.com
twist that's right a free ebook and one
month three after attending a free demo
at com.com
twist once again get started today
calm.com
twist thanks again to com for making
such great
products